[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show we're
getting close to 700 episodes crazy to
think and my guest today long overdue is
Jason calacanus
don't leave out the second a folks he
has invested in more than 300 startups
in the past decade with Sequoia
capital's first Scout and is the author
of the book Angel he also hosts two
podcasts we're going to talk quite a bit
about this week in startups and all in
you can find them online at calacanes
that's
c-a-l-a-c-a-n-i-s.com and on Twitter at
Jason because he was an early bird on
the Twitter platform Jason nice to see
you man it's nice to see you brother
you and I have random phone calls for
like an hour or two and I think this is
the first time we're actually recording
it it's the first time
I listened to I would say two out of
three of your episodes you think you've
had a lot of investors on I have I have
somebody's like how come you haven't
been on Tim first Pockets I'm like
he's got so many investors on what can I
add right and I'm sure at some point
there's a lot well sure I'm sure but I
mean it is so great to see how well your
podcast has done over the years oh
thanks man so I remember
the first time I met you in Tahoe with I
guess Saka and it was like hey this is a
four hour work week guy and I was like
you know how hard you're making my life
oh all these Founders I mean now I think
they can work four hours I started
breaking your chops
uh it's part of the trial yeah it's part
of the charm good to see you it is good
to see you and so you I consider
a master of podcasting we're gonna come
back to that because I have some other
questions maybe before that but I wanted
to give an example of a great piece of
tactical advice and you actually told me
about this before we started recording
QuickTime so we are both running back up
QuickTime audio so we have extra local
copies in case something breaks because
things often break what was the what was
the tactic that you shared because it's
so smart
you load a QuickTime thing and you're
like hey can you start a quick time
people go oh yeah my quicktime's running
but then one out of three times at the
end of the show we're like okay can you
help the question I'm like oh I didn't
hit the record button so instead of
asking can you you know record a quick
time and say how many seconds is your
QuickTime running
and they say it's 36 seconds now I know
it's running and but the bigger piece is
there's this book uh the checklist
Manifesto you and I obsessed with yeah
probably part of our kinship a tool go
on day yeah we're both into like tools
and optimization and this book I had
heard Jack from Twitter would give it to
every Square employee give it to every
Twitter employee the checklist Manifesto
and I make everybody read it I'm
obsessed with checklists and so you know
because people forget people forget and
all those great stories in the book
about like surgeons and Pilots were like
oh incredible I don't need a checklist
and then everybody dies yeah
and then a nurse comes along and it's
like well I could just make this little
checklist for you and we could just you
know you say something I say okay you
say something I say okay and then all of
a sudden you could have a plane with
four engines yeah because people had
more discipline you know and it's like
oh I know you guys didn't need this
checklist but we have bacterial line
infections down by 39 this year oh go
look at that yeah it's it's a great book
people would take a scalpel that was
dirty and they made this little device
right
these little life hacks you know that
are so much a part of what you do
and by the way it's super weird for you
to tell me that I'm a podcast Master
because I take notes on your podcast
works both ways anyway they would put a
little tent on top of the clean
instrument so like a clean scalpel would
have a tent on top
and the nurse was responsible for
cleaning everything and putting the
tents on so then they knew it was clean
and you take the tent off
now it's been used so tent on means
clean don't put the tent on a dirty
scalpel tent off no bueno no bueno
now you can't believe everything you
read on the internet so please correct
me if I'm getting any of this wrong but
yeah sure you know your mom was tending
to people in the ER your dad had a had a
bar as I understand it there were times
when you would be cleaning blood off the
floor from all the brawls and fights for
sure and then and then rated at one
point I think by the I don't know if it
was the FBI but with like tax
authorities tax authorities my dad got a
little behind on the taxes yeah the
taxes they sneak up on you it turns out
the tax Authority they're kind of
humorless like Fair taxes or you go to
jail and so when I was 18 years old
growing up in Bay Ridge Brooklyn which
is the last stop on the train just to
give you an idea of how far out there it
is
this in the 70s and 80s in 1988 my dad's
bar
after the stock market crashed he went
into basically debt and it was really
gnarly and then
One Summer Afternoon in July the feds
basically and the tax Authority came and
padlocked the place took everything out
of it and you know this close to my dad
going to jail and had you know one of
the great traumas of my life and I just
one of the things I really appreciate
and respect about you is you shared your
trauma on this podcast it's a gift to
the world you know that's a pretty scary
thing when you're 17 years old and
you're like Dad says
I'm sorry son I don't have money for
college
I'm probably going to jail I tried to
make this business work it didn't work
take care of your mom like whoa it's
kind of like that scene when if you
remember the Empire Strikes Back and
like Han Solo comes over to Chewbacca
it's like
just take care of the princess I'll be
back yeah it was really intense
brilliant yeah yeah I bet that's
crazy but that really is like my life
just got crazier and crazier after that
right like so I forged such a crazy
childhood that was so violent and crazy
and just Brooklyn when it wasn't cool
that it kind of made when I went into
business just kind of like well I don't
have to worry about somebody jumping me
there's no violence here like I'm not
going to be murdered I'm not going to
jail it's like wow this is easier but I
didn't know that world existed you know
the only world I knew was the people who
hung out of my dad's bar the mafia
the Hell's Angels
a bunch of cops some percentage of which
were in on the take with the other two
groups uh and then a bunch of Wall
Street people and so it was like out of
a film like Goodfellas Tim my kid you're
not like I would
I would have to go serve espresso to the
bookie yeah or the the dealer or the
head of the hell's the Angels like it
was Bonkers and you know it just made me
really good at dealing with people I
think yeah I would imagine you developed
a lot of situational awareness
adaptations right yeah you get a lot of
adaptations real quick when you're
dealing with those different types of
individuals but I look back on it now
and I'm like
did that really happen
what's happening in my life now and I'm
like is this really happening so it's
been a pretty Surreal Life the whole way
I have to say so if we Flash Forward a
little bit
and we don't necessarily have to spend a
ton of time on this but silicon alley
reporter in the beginning I mean you're
photocopying it yourself you're hand
delivering to coffee shops and other
spots yeah did you know or decide you
were going into business for yourself to
be an entrepreneur and I ask especially
given what you saw happen to your dad
right I can see some people responding
by going entirely in the opposite
direction getting the safest nine to
five possible so how did you end up
an entrepreneur
so having a dad who's an entrepreneur
kind of puts it in you yeah and I you
know had one or two jobs
when I was in college I went to college
at night so I was I would fix Laser
Printers and build networks this is
before the internet existed you would
have to connect computers together with
coaxial cables and create what's called
a local area network and I did a couple
of those jobs and it was well paying and
it helped me pay for college because
remember my dad had no money so I had to
pay for all this on my own took me five
years to go through school at night
but when I would ride the train in
I would look at people reading magazines
and then I would go to cafes because you
know sort of pre the web and mobile
phones and we'd go hang out in cafes you
know in the Lower East Side Bleaker
Street wherever the village you know
when I was in college we go play chess
On Bleecker Street or read magazines or
free newspapers
and I just looked at the people who are
in the pictures to him and I was like
why aren't they in the on the cover of
the magazine why why is this person on
the cover of spy magazine why is this
person that cover paper magazine why are
people important all I knew was nurses
doctors lawyers cops firefighters that's
all I was exposed to I didn't understand
there was other stuff in the world then
I went to school in Manhattan at night
and I would work in Manhattan during the
day and I was looking around going
oh who's that person getting out of that
like limousine to go into that big tall
building what's in that picture oh those
are Apartments like it was really weird
like being dropped on an alien planet
because Brooklyn was so different than
Manhattan at the time yeah for sure
Brooklyn was a bunch of blue-collar
people Manhattan were rich people uh and
powerful people and so something just
clicked in my brain and I said I want to
be powerful
I want to be rich I want to be on the
cover of a magazine and I started
looking at the magazines and then I
discovered the Masthead
and I saw the Masthead and I said wait a
second what's the who's the publisher
and the editor-in-chief who has more
power
who is this editor at large that sounds
more important but wait it's in a
smaller font and lower and then I
started to meet people and I started
asking him like what's this what's that
and I was at a party I ran into somebody
at Barney somebody had invited me to a
party in the basement of Barney's I'm
talking to this guy and I said what do
you do and he said oh I I work at a
magazine I said what magazine do you
work let me pause for a second Barney's
sounds fancy how did you get invited to
the party you know what I just was
hanging out in the downtown scene where
a company called Voyager was making
CD-ROMs
blenders making CD-ROMs a friend of mine
Josh Harris was doing pseudo and he was
doing online chat rooms with Prodigy so
I was just hanging around with the tech
scene there and it was probably 50
people who were in The Tech scene
because the only thing that existed were
online services dial up cop user Prodigy
the well it was just a small set of
dial-up services and I knew how to use a
modem and I knew about the internet so I
kind of started to meet those people and
then those people started to tip over
into the media business in New York yeah
and because the media business was very
attractive to oh you can dial up and
read an article people started to put
these connections together magazines
plus a dial-up service Music Plus a
dial-up service booking a ticket to a
movie a dial-up service so and oh a
CD-ROM has a video on it or it has a an
article so you could make a CD-ROM with
an article end so this multimedia thing
happened and then I was at Sony setting
up their computer networks when the
internet happened and then Sony was
going to build a website and so I was on
the website team and the website was
a picture of 10 Sony logos Sony Music
Columbia Records we literally said 10
people in a room designing a web page
with 10 logos on it that was the
entirety of the website was one page and
then like a 12-page legal disclaimer so
this is very interesting like moment in
time and uh I said what magazine he said
paper magazine he said
you work in paper magazine and he said I
created paper magazine
I said what do you mean you created it
like you're working the printer said no
no I'm the editor-in-chief I'm David
hershkowitz
I said tell me everything so I start
talking to him he says why don't you
come by my office because I'm setting up
my dial up
and I said okay and I go down to his
office which was sort of where Balthazar
is now on Broadway at Lower Broadway and
you know I help him with his internet
and we're talking about dial-up Services
you should write a column for us about
the internet and this technology stuff
so I started writing for paper magazine
and I was like this little nerdy kid and
I didn't know how to write I didn't know
how to spell I didn't know how to put a
comma in a sentence and Christine
mulhucky was my editor she was like 20
something years old I was 20 something
years old started writing for paper
magazine then hershkovitz is like
he was really getting into the internet
and I remained friends with him to this
day 30 years later and he would just ask
me to come by the office I hang out I'm
hanging out a paper magazine and he's
like hey you want to go
to a concert tonight yeah sure so yeah
we're gonna go uh to the Roxy
this is a new band Chemical Brothers can
be playing orb's gonna be opening for
them and then we're in like the green
room or the the VIP room waiting to go
on and he's like oh Jason uh this is I
meet this woman from Iceland and I'm
like oh Iceland where is that is that
like Norway or Sweden she's like no it's
like over here and she's talking really
low and I'm like so what do you do she's
like we'll have a wreck coming out I'm
like oh that's awesome what kind of
music is this like these guys no I just
I'm singers oh I'm Jason and she goes
I'm Bjork yeah this is New York in the
90s I mean it was cool as F like yeah
yeah it was and it was the Zeitgeist was
crazy and so all of this starts to
spiral and I just said I need to make a
magazine and David had showed me the
early issues of paper yeah and paper
magazine was original never heard you
censor your cursing before that was very
delicate it's a family show I think you
could curse it's okay
don't tell a Kid From Brooklyn
hearing poor editors
here we go we have 47 [ __ ] in the first
30 minutes
47 [ __ ] again so anyway it's actually
kind of fun to remember all the stuff so
he starts he takes me to the archive
room a paper magazine which was a glossy
at the time and he says look
it was a foldable thing I got a foldable
piece of paper and I folded it and we
would just put it for free you know in
cafes and I was like
you know when like The Terminator
you see from his View and like all the
words are going by and he's just like
processing everything really fast that
was happening in my brain I was like
okay wait free Fold It print it what
okay do this I'm taking all of these
instructions and I literally
went to Tower Records which is a place
where they used to sell CDs and Records
oh yeah and they had a Zine section and
zines were short for magazine z-i-n-e
for people who are under the age of 40.
and this was like the most punk rock
thing you could do after being in a punk
rock band was to start a Zine and azine
just meant you got your friends together
and wrote an article together and then
you would photocopy so 2600 famously was
a Zine about hacking in New York and I
had met the founder of that
so there's like a little Zine culture
going on and I was like huh
all my friends are starting internet
stuff I'm writing about the internet
once a month I write 400 roads I could
write 40 000 words I got four thousand
words whatever
and people had never been to San
Francisco or Silicon Valley but people
were starting somebody referred to what
we were doing as silicon alley
silicon alley
that's rad
and then I had seen somebody I was like
well I should be a reporter about
silicon alley I could do like a Silicon
Valley Reporter and it'd just be me
reporting on what's Happening here
because this is cool like there's like
now it's like 200 people doing stuff
and so I just started a photocopy called
silicon eye reporter
and I went up to the Village printing
shop on 43rd Street and 6th Avenue and
every every time I'm in New York I like
to walk when I'm in New York just to
remind myself of that those moments in
time and I always walk down that block
to see if it's there Village printer I
know it's still there but a couple years
ago it's still there and it was 24 hours
and I brought it to the guy and I he
he's there's a thing called tabloid
paper you know eight and a half by
eleven plus eight and a half by eleven
equals whatever it is you know like the
17 by whatever and uh you could take
that paper fold it and put a staple in
the middle and it would look like a a
newsletter and so I said okay that's the
format I got pagemaker I started laying
it out I took pictures I wrote a couple
articles and I went there and I printed
and he said yeah it's gonna be like 10
cents a photocopy and I was like all
right 80 cents an issue
I could do this
so guys I mean make me a thousand copies
800 bucks right
and I'm just going to start handing them
out like David hirschevitz did and I go
and he hands me a bill for 17.50.
and I said wait you said 10 cents it's
eight pages he's double-sided he says
double side I said I don't have the
money
he goes what do you mean you don't have
money I got a thousand copies of Silicon
Valley Reporter so I started talking to
the guy now I'm gonna I'm hagging with
him and he's just the overnight manager
and he said listen
I I don't have the money for this like I
just my credit card's maxed out
can you do me a favor like maybe someday
I could do you a favor I could put an ad
in there
it's like don't tell anybody okay and I
was like no I won't tell anybody you
know they got to counter on these things
I could get busted and I was like I
don't want you to get busted he's like
I don't know man this team's really cool
just give me 800 bucks and I just gave
me 100 bucks
then I realized like I started to learn
a very interesting lesson in my life
that when I ask people things
that
many times people will do what I ask
them to do
like a Jedi kind of trick no but this
guy did it out of the kindness of his
soul but I kind of started to learn
early in my career like you could ask
for things in the world
even sometimes outrageous things
and sometimes it happens right
and I took them over to Roseland where
there was a internet party going on or
like a rosen's a venue like a music
venue and there's some some electronic
music president played and then like a
bunch of Internet multimedia people were
going to be hanging out so I walk over
there I dropped off mostly
issues at my little office I had like a
little office share and then I took like
200 of my backpack and in my hands to
the party I get to the party at like one
in the morning and I just start handing
them to people and I had like this
Moment of clarity in my life
I gave away people started coming up to
me to get them
and then I turn around and look at the
party which was popping off
and every single person has the magazine
open the zine open the photocopy and
he's reading it with two or three people
around them the entire party stopped so
what did that feel like like what
happened to you and that when you saw
that power ah okay tell me more I got
the power you got the power and so
remember I said I had no power as a
child and they take your dad's bar yeah
like we're going deep into the trauma
work here
listen I I you know I consider a
privilege to be on here and you've
shared a lot like and if this helps
other people but you know when you don't
have power and you're a kid and you live
a scared life uh which I did and then
all of a sudden
the entire party in Manhattan is in the
palm of your hand
and something you created
has stopped everybody dead in their
tracks
the adrenaline and the confidence it
felt like you know all of a sudden
Superman like figures out like
you know when he reaches Into the Fire
to get something he dropped it's like oh
the Fire doesn't burn me whoa I can fly
like just this incredible Wing sprouted
and I was like wait a second I could be
an entrepreneur I could do something in
the world and the next day I was
had it my phone was ringing people were
calling me and then I just made a set of
postcards that said subscribe to the
Silicon Valley Reporter 10 issues a year
90 dollars
and I had seen Esther Dyson charged a
thousand dollars for her newsletter so I
was like well she's Esther Dyson so I
charge 10 maybe that's the same thing
Esther Dyson was this famous you know uh
yeah angel investor and I just when I
went out I didn't have the magazine on
me I had the cards or just hand the
cards and then within two or three
months I would get to my office share
and there would be a stack of envelopes
and it would be 20 people sent me 90
dollars that's 1800 mailbox every day
four thousand dollars six thousand
dollars and all of a sudden it was like
thirty forty thousand dollars people
subscribing
you know and it was kind of like the
Kevin Kelly like you only need two
thousand true fans yeah and then all of
a sudden I was like wait a second I can
quit my jobs I can do this I'm David
hershovitz and Kim from paper I did it
yeah and it was like whoa
and this all happened within 60 days wow
from a nobody trying to get into a party
to meet somebody to all of a sudden
every CEO and person trying to meet me
and it was basically like this all of a
sudden becomes the sliding door kind of
moment of your life like some random
occurrence happened I meet David
hershkowitz at a party I get this guy to
print out the things I go to that party
and drop them off and all of a sudden
I'm important
um but remember
I wasn't covering tennis I wasn't
covering wine I was covering this new
thing called the internet
when the browser didn't support Graphics
so the timing was so insane because the
intern you talk about this foreign
that was the start of a great life for a
very simple man
laughs
so I'm so glad we're talking about the
early days because of course I had no
idea of a lot of but you had the same
thing nobody knew who you were you're
some guy and you all of a sudden this
four hour work week goes from yeah like
you got paid nothing for that book
nothing and then all of a sudden it was
it wasn't it the same exact experience
it was similar it was similar yeah I was
very similar I remember when the book
came out and I got a call from my editor
Heather Jackson at the time and she said
why hello Mr New York Times best-selling
author and I had just finished a day of
radio satellite tours which people did
back in the day they may still do them
and I would had two pots of coffee and I
was just exhausted and I and I sat down
on the floor and I was and I said
Heather don't [ __ ] with me I'm too tired
and she said I'm serious no you made it
you're 15 on the extended list so not in
print but you're on the list technically
whoa and I thought to myself oh wow
things are about to change
things you're about to change and all of
a sudden you know let's call it within
the next few weeks you know it kept
growing and then it stayed on the list
for stayed on the print list for I want
to say four years plus unbroken and in
the beginning started getting these
calls asking me to speak offering to pay
me for Keynotes I mean none of this had
happened before
and it was mind-blowing bewildering yeah
very bewildering the speaking gig is an
interesting moment yeah because you work
your whole life you make 30 grand 40
Grand a year
and then this kind of stuff happens to
you and then somebody calls it oh a Tim
would you like to come speak at this
corporate thing and you're like uh why
would I speak there oh well you know
your book and and you're like okay and
they're like well of course we'd like to
give you an honorarium and you're like
okay and they're like and it's thirty
thousand dollars
and you're like say what that's what I
made last year come again
thirty three thousand dollars at a zero
thirty thousand and you're just like
that makes no sense and they're like
well it's gonna be two hours your time
we don't want to put you out Mr Ferris
they're like can I do it tomorrow too
it is a mind-blowing experience I always
like I literally just had one of these
coming today some corporate gig and you
know because all it has gotten so
popular all of a sudden now people want
me to speak at a bunch of stuff again
and it's just like the numbers are
mind-boggling and you're just like isn't
it very weird yeah how like you can go
from being an absolute nobody to
somebody wanting to give you tens of
thousands to speak for an hour that
really screwed up my mind a lot also
because I had a lot of feelings of guilt
and stuff about my parents and I was
like you're offering me a speed speaking
gig which is what my mom or dad made in
a year in a year yeah it's weird you
also had this same situation yes so it
really does screw with your head and
it's very hard to stay grounded or
figure out what's actually happening
right yeah so let's talk about another
holy [ __ ] moment and this is January of
99 you're offered 20 million I believe
it's a true story and the conference
business so I'm reading here this is
from Fast Company and it talks about
your interaction with Douglas rushkoff
oh Doug rushcoff yeah my friend in New
York yeah yeah yeah that was another guy
who taught me so much I love Doug so
walk me through getting this offer the
conversations you had the decision you
made
and then
what if anything you kind of take from
that to this day if you wouldn't mind
the magazine had gotten very big and it
became a color glossy I had almost 100
people working for me it was 300 pages
and it was during the.com boom we're
talking about 1999 now right so the
magazine is doing you know six seven
eight million a year I'd done an event
or two that started making two or three
million so now we're like I got 11
million dollar company I built up my
credit cards and I was making
just you know a couple years earlier
minimum wage to work in the computer
room at uh Fordham which was 350 an hour
and then I was fixing Laser Printers for
nine dollars an hour and then I got a
job at Amnesty International doing their
internal Network for 12 an hour
so all this happens in a very short
period of time and you know again for a
poor kid from Brooklyn I'm just trying
to navigate it and this guy Alan macro
had internet.com he took it publicly
became more than a billion dollars and
you offered me 20 million bucks
for Silicon Valley Reporter but it was
my identity yeah and it was making 10
million and I was like I don't want to
give up my identity
but I thought about it I said well if I
could if I can clear a million or two
million dollars a year off the magazine
in profits it'd be the same amount of
money so maybe I wouldn't do it and then
the.com bus happens and I lose
everything
and I wind up selling the scraps of the
business to Dow Jones and they give me
two years of salary and the Magazine's
dead and I get two years at three
hundred thousand dollars maybe five or
six hundred thousand dollars in like
this employment agreement
and they paid off all the bills because
I then had like my dad I was in arrears
when the magazine collapsed if you got a
magazine about the internet and the
internet collapses tough business not
only did I not have any money all the
money that was owed to me never showed
up ugh because of all the companies have
gone out of business I was like you owe
me for three ads they're like the phone
number didn't pick up like the company
was shut down then I show up for work at
Dow Jones and they say hey can we take
you for a walk like manage manager guy
and I'm like sure what okay sure we'll
go for a walk listen you know you're so
talented we don't think you know this we
can you know you being here and you're
so talented and I'm like yeah
so you know like you should go do
something else and I'm like are you
firing me and they're like yeah we don't
need your services I was like you just
bought my company and that 20 you know
had like 20 people left and they had
reassigned them to this other Venture
Capital thing they were doing they said
you don't want me
chasing Colin canis the Silicon Valley
Reporter to work here
they said no I said I just signed a
contract with you for 600 you know five
or six hundred thousand dollars they
said yeah and he pulls out an envelope
and he hands me a check for 500 000. he
says we're paying out your contract
Tim you're the first person I've told
these stories to wow this is like
literally like the crazy life I've lived
and I am looking at a 500 000 check
which which is a extraordinary amount of
money obviously
and the only thing I can think is I want
to beat the [ __ ] out of this guy uh just
[ __ ] fired me yeah they don't want me
yeah I went from being a nobody
to running New York being on Charlie
Rose being on the cover of the New York
Times having a New Yorker thing being
written about me you know just living
like the peak New York experience yeah
living in a loft in Manhattan sitting at
you know in the first three or four rows
of the Knicks games hanging out with
Alan Houston
you know the number one star on the next
time I mean I was living it a peak
and then overnight boom everything's
gone
I got a 500K check in my hand
and nothing
nobody wants me
and I got so the rage
and I felt in that moment was like
hulk-like rage like I was a Berserker
like the Samurai armor just took the
sword out and I was like I am going to
prove I can do this again
I am going to show everybody
that this was not a fluke it made me
I've never felt more rage in my life I
don't think but I've been in some pretty
big brawls and so then I just took the
money I got an office and the next day I
said I gotta build something
I gotta build something the next day the
next day I was like literally got an
office share my friend's office I said
can I get a desk and it was like you
know I was like that blank sheet of
paper in 2002 2003 I gotta figure
something out
what's next and I just started making
designs on whiteboards yeah I was gonna
ask like that day how do you even begin
with such a blue sky blank page yeah how
did you even start were you just pulling
from random
bits and pieces floating around did you
have some approach I started calling
people up I started calling people out
what are you working on
what's happening and then you know like
this one person was making this photo
sharing site flicker another person was
doing a bookmarking site called
delicious there's just this
little underground of people who were
building stuff for the web because the
web had gotten Advanced now in the
second decade and the web pages could
refresh themselves with Ajax and they
were kind of tables got became more
responsive and there were all these like
new technical things and then editorial
formats people were playing with
and I was like huh
who's doing anything and then there was
just like one group doing like
journaling on the web
another group that was
you know trying to do like photo sharing
and follow your friends
huh
and then I had somebody who would work
for me named rafid Ali and he'll start
let me intro for one second so the
reason you're calling these people is
not because you want to work with them
on what they're doing necessarily or was
it or or were you just no trying to get
more like a landscape it's literally
just trying to network with people who I
had known and I was literally asking
people like what's going on
like what is anybody doing anything cool
yeah and I just started looking for
people doing cool projects just to see
what was going to happen after the.com
bus because everybody quit and everybody
went and got jobs that I got companies
so you're trying to get a read of the of
the playing field to see where the pucks
might be going next exactly is there
anything interesting in the world I'm
mixing my sports metaphors but you get
the idea I'm talking about field hockey
everybody yeah yeah okay let's just say
like Tim first when he learns a sport
it's wild to watch watching Tim first
learn a sport it's hilarious because I
taught him how to do a layup it is fun I
don't know how to dribble a basketball
it was hilarious that's another story it
is funny and also if you learn a sport
with Jake owl you aren't going to have
to listen to so much [ __ ] yeah
he will torture you at every opportunity
yeah watching Tim Ferriss go from like
being a perfect fencer or perfect yoga
you know in negative 100 degree and then
he tries to dribble a basketball it's
literally like looking like a drunk
person with a blindfold on oh yeah but
to your credit true story I watched you
learn how to do a layup and I gave you
you asked me like three or four
questions and you went from looking like
you were blind and drunk to all of a
sudden doing a layup in under like three
minutes perfectly and I was like yeah
that's Tim ferriss's gift he knows how
to ask the right questions and like
watching you process it's actually
impressive thanks man but anyway it was
like one of those moments where you're
like
what's next in the world I was just
trying to figure out what was next and
so I was just because also so many
people were out of work
that if you couldn't get a job you kind
of just started tinkering which is kind
of how multimedia started so I was like
I've seen this before
technology keeps going people are
starting to Tinker and Wi-Fi had come
out at that time I was very fascinated
about Wi-Fi and I was thinking about
Wi-Fi routers and putting Wi-Fi in
places and you know maybe you could have
internet and cafes and stuff it's just
like all kinds of crazy little ideas and
I started whiteboarding stuff I started
Cosmo had gone out of business the
delivery service so the first idea I had
was for mercury club and I was going to
get a hundred New Yorkers and give them
Mercury Club number one two three four
five all the way to 100 I was gonna give
one to Charlie Rose one to Howard Stern
and my idea was to get a bunch of people
on Vespas because I had gotten a Vespa
and I was driving around New York and I
realized because I had driven one in
Barcelona I was like if you're in a city
a bike's too slow a car's too slow and a
Vespa goes fast because you can just
weave in and out traffic and I had
seeing Cosmo had started experimenting
with Investments and I said I'm going to
create a service
where you pay a hundred dollars a month
for rich people and you get four hours
of deliveries 25 bucks an hour this is
when you know minimum wage was six or
seven bucks but this is only for rich
people and if you needed a bottle of
wine or a pack of cigarettes whatever
you would just
call an 800 number because 800 numbers
were another like platform like they
became zines for a while one eight
hundred flowers one eight hundred
bachelor's 1-800 everything and so I
started looking into buying a 1-800
number because I was just always very
interested in mediums right because if
you get to a medium first you can
exploit it yeah whether it's podcasting
like you and I did or blogging like I
did and you did I think or scenes
starting 2005 blog yeah so like if you
get to it first you get to play with it
first you get a disproportionate amount
of credit for being there first just
like you know if you go to Austin first
or you go to you know Bed Stuy Brooklyn
first you get the cool Loft that you
bought for nothing and then everybody
else comes and your loss goes up in
value right so the value of the platform
goes up as the people who tinker and
create it get to play with it right so I
never really actually thought about it
but it is true yeah and so I also got
the 800 number so yeah 1-800 Mercury I
said trying to get a Mercury Club number
and my idea was the wreaths because I
remember I talking to the guy who had
done Cosmo because I covered it in my
magazine
and he said yeah I just I should have
just charged a delivery fee
because he the last six months they
started charging a delivery fee and he
said yeah the business worked in three
of the nine cities if I had only charged
delivery fees I was like why didn't you
he's like VCS told me not to just wanted
to grow and we're trying to get public
just literally the same lesson people
are learning now so I was like well wait
instead of charging a delivery fee why
don't I just make it like because I knew
bike Messengers bike messenger culture
was like a big thing in New York so the
Bike Masters used to hang out outside
where my loft was because it was
business Commercial Loft the star of
Lehigh building in New York It was a
commercial and we were living there
illegally me DJ Spooky a couple of our
artists were living in these illegal
Lofts anyway the bike Messengers were
out all the time
they were smoking weed and just it was
like it was like a very cool culture
because they had figured out life they
would make like 10 bucks per run they
could do two runs an hour and they got
to just bomb these bikes all over
Manhattan and they got exercise they
were fit they were smoking weed
listening to music it was like the
coolest gig ever I was like these guys
they figured out life
like you get to ride your bike all day
smoke dope listen to cool music joke
with your friends and you just drop off
an envelope now and again and you make
more money than the people you're
dropping off the envelope to but you're
outside that's just it was like a crazy
Revelation I had so I was like yeah I'm
gonna do Mercury club and I built the
whole business model
for mercury Club
how did you land on the name
well Mercury like the god with the wings
on the feet and not just like it came to
I was Greek I always like the Greek god
so I was just like yeah kind of started
thinking about like fast and I just
thought well this would be incredible
can you imagine you're like at like your
Charlie Rose at a party or David
hershkowitz from paper and you're just
like yeah oh you should we get
cigarettes yeah and you just pick out
your because mobile phones have come out
at that time so imagine taking out your
star attack and I had seen a star attack
phone those little flip phones it's like
imagine you take that out you dial an
800 number and you say yeah I need two
packs of Marlboro Lights and uh you know
bring me the a copy of Vanity Fair or
Esquire magazine because I'm at a party
I want to show somebody and then just
somebody comes there and hands it to you
yeah like the ultimate luxury like the
ultimate power move like I can just call
my assistant and just get anything I
want anyway
I didn't wind up building that so Greek
your name is Greek what does your last
name
means
means to have done well or good for you
so sometimes when I use my credit card
and a Greek person does it they're like
good for you or you've done well very
nice but it's with K's so when my
grandfather went through Ellis Island
God Rest assault
they were like Galaxy here's your banana
keep moving and I was like no it's case
and they were just like [ __ ] you
calcanas here's your business no that
you should give bananas that was Island
iron that's real yeah it was like some
weird thing where they just would give
everybody who comes in like a banana
because they were hungry off the boats
and bananas were a lot of bananas were
coming in from South America to Ellis
Island as well so they're just like here
have a banana keep moving today I
learned let me keep it moving and then
the crazy thing Tim is I was on the
Ellis Island website and on the Ellis
Island website I searched for my last
name and they had archived everything
and calacanus my grandfather went
through like 12 times and it turned out
he was in the merchant marines he was an
engine captain and I knew that but every
time he came back to America with human
passengers
he had to sign in again and so he has
gone through it like 12 times wow
that's wild yeah and I was like wow he's
coming from Brazil he's coming from
Ireland he's coming from Italy he's
coming from everywhere in the world the
cargo was humans it was Americans that's
incredible pretty crazy right that is
wild so anyway I had watched the blog
stuff happen
and two people who had worked for me
Shani Jardin was my event producer she
had been working for a famous Law Firm
Latham Watkins they were a sponsor of
one of my events she did a great job at
the event I asked Latham can I hire her
because she's awesome and rad and I
hired Jenny to come work with me at
silicon everybody she would produce my
events
and then when everything shut down she
started working on this like boing boing
thing and I'm like yeah what are you
doing with your wife she was like yeah
we write blog posts I'm like
logs logs and I was like like Rafael Ali
was doing so this kid who had worked for
me Rafa Ali was doing a Blog on the site
called pay content.org
and uh somebody ratted him out when he
was working at the magazine and he was
Moonlighting now back in the day you
couldn't have a side hustle that was
like instant firing
so I call him into my office I'm like
you got something to tell me kid
he's like no I'm like you sure you don't
have anything to tell me
he's like is it about pay content and
I'm like yeah
I'm like what are you doing he's like
I'm just writing about people who are
charging for content on the internet I'm
like Hey kid information wants to be
free nobody's paying for content on the
internet he goes actually I think you're
wrong hold on kid let me stop you number
one
nobody's paying for Content the whole
reason we started the internet is
information wants to be free number two
you're not a great writer
I'm your editor
who's your editor for paid content.org
you can say I don't have another it's a
Blog I'm like
no publication will ever work
if there is not an editorial structure
it will fail because there'll be
spelling errors
you're gonna write stupid headlines you
need an editor that's how this works
he's like am I fired I'm like no just
focus on work and stop doing stupid [ __ ]
on the weekend back to your desk I just
like admonished now I'm an investor in
this company now skiffed but that
accepted in me because when we shut down
I had talked to Shannon I talked to
Rocket and Rob's like yeah I'm making
like four grand a month on ads I'm like
I was paying you 35k you're making 4K
now you're making 48 you're making 13
000 more than when you work for me and
then Chinese like I'm getting a 5k draw
a month yeah I'm like what I'm like how
how many hours a day do you work she's
like look like it's like two hours in
the morning and then like at night I
come home I do like two or three hours
or something
you know this is before the four hour
work week
and this is during the 60 hour reality
of being a worker and I was like blogs
huh
and then I started reading blogs and I
was like you know there's something here
blogs are dope
blogs
even though they have spelling errors in
them
come out faster than magazines and
newspaper articles they're faster faster
is always better
it's faster I said and for the right
Rider
it's spicy like oh shanny's spicy
and I remember like I wouldn't have let
her her write that I would have stopped
her
and then I was dead you know just like
when I saw all the magazines and
everybody had them I just all of a
sudden the Terminator everything clicked
at once Tim I was like
it's faster and it's better
it's faster it's better it's cheaper
faster better cheaper wait I had heard
Marvin Minsky and Kevin Kelly and all
these guys at like a conference like a
Ted at some point talking about faster
better cheaper I didn't understand what
they meant but
literally was that like Ted and they
were at like one of brockman's dinners
and they were talking about faster
better cheap or whatever pick two and I
didn't understand what they were talking
about but it it had kind of another
Inception moment I was like wait a
second
what if you had a hundred of them so
then I I called Brian Alvey who had
worked with me on the magazines and I
said let's go to the next game
went to the next game and I said what if
we had web logs these blogs were Vision
called weblogs because they were on the
web and they were logs and then people
dropped the wa and they became blogs you
remember all this but a little history
lesson for those listening and so I was
like
what if we did web logs for business
nobody's ever done a business topic so
we'll do web logs and he goes oh yeah we
should call it weblogs Inc
and then he got the domain name and then
we started building them and we did a
web log on Wi-Fi we did a web log on
apple and then we started building all
these ones and in
under in 18 months we had built 87 blogs
we had 200 000 in total revenue and AOL
bought it for 30 million dollars and we
had one investor my friend Mark Cuban
had put 300 000 in for 20 percent of the
company or something and I gave him six
million back and then Brian and I and uh
Peter Rojas put the rest and uh in 18
months after my 20 million dollar offer
had gone away I got the 30 million
dollar wrong that's just insane that's
just insane the Berserker insane jcal
I'm gonna prove it to the world proved
it and then I was like
yeah I just like looked at the sword
took the armor off hung it up I was like
yep
I could do it I can do it anytime I want
anytime I want I can build a brand a
business and I can just get it from zero
to whatever yeah I might fail two out of
three times but I could do it
and that was when it was like okay you
know once you're like yeah once you're
lucky twice you're good yeah it was my
once you're lucky twice you're a good
moment because then everybody would
watch me fail and kind of danced on My
Grave at Silicon Valley Reporter
was like oh God all right the cat came
back the very next day we thought he
wasn't gone but he wouldn't stay away
there's a lot of people who are just
like oh he's going to be insufferable
after this
they weren't wrong
just a couple of maybe boring
housekeeping questions yeah sure I'm
thinking of the timing of building these
web logs yeah how did you find the
writers to do this
a great thing for people to understand
right now in this moment of time we're
taping this in 2022 the market crashed
and Facebook laid off 11 000 people
yesterday
yeah I don't want to date this too much
I don't know when you're going to oh
that's okay it'll come out reasonably
soon I mean but people as as a snapshot
in time also I mean cryptos having a
complete implosion FDX is going through
the meat grinder people are probably
going to go to jail yeah jail 32 billion
dollars eviscerated actually wanted to
talk to you about like people who commit
fraud and lie because I was interested
in perspective on it because I just
can't imagine it because the system is
so easy to win yeah and the system is
set up for entrepreneurs to win in this
country like why on Earth would you
cheat if it's so easy to just have a win
by just working hard anyway but I
interrupted you because you were you
were tying the web logs and artists and
so on so it's very simple everybody was
out of work and so I just when you hired
a writer you'd say do you know anybody
and the original deal was we started
going to people who were doing like live
Journal blogs and like we'd find
somebody who had written a Blog about
Apple Sean Bonner yeah Sean Bonner yeah
and I said hey Sean um I'm doing this
weblogs Inc thing we're gonna try to
sell ads on blogs he's like well that's
stupid I'm like yeah but I think I could
figure it out because I did a magazine
he's like all right that's pretty smart
I was like would you write I see you're
writing some apple blogs could we put
them on our Apple blog or if I gave you
the login would you post them because
Brian Alvey who's a genius he's now
running WordPress for for melon wig oh
no kidding I'm WordPress like Pro VIP
that you like people like you know yeah
yeah yeah that automatic yeah at
automatic and so anyway it was a great
collaborator of my career
it's kind of my uh George Harrison or
yeah Paul to my Lennon or vice versa
yeah built the software that was better
than everybody it's better than typeform
better than blogger better than
everything and uh I just gave Sean the
login and I was like listen I want to
pay you something
because I want to own the blog posts
he's like you want to own a paragraph of
me writing about a Macbook it's three
sentences Jason it's worthless
I'll do it for free and I was like I'll
tell you what
how many a day could you do about Apple
products it's like two I was like okay
260. I'll give you 150 bucks a month
cash
to just let us run these over here it's
a paragraph each he's like I can write
these in 10 minutes like you're an idiot
but sure I'll take
whatever it is two or three dollars a
blog post
so we just started hiring people and
then we made it five bucks a blog post
eventually ten bucks a blog post and
people thought were stupid because
minimum wage at the time was 10 bucks
and people were like I wrote three blog
posts this hour and you gave me thirty
dollars but I had done a spreadsheet
with Brian and I said here's how many
pages were getting here's what I think
we could make per page view
here's what the cost is for blog post
all we have to do with this business is
scale it and then somebody will buy it
and he said yeah I think you're right I
said you do the tech I'll get the
writers and the advertising I'll see you
on the other side and we both put our
heads down for 18 months and we had 450
bloggers in the system of which maybe
200 were active and we were pounding out
thousands of blog posts a week
across 87 different topics and then AOL
found out about what we're doing and
they had looked at Gawker and they had
looked at us and in gadget was crushing
Gawker because we stole Peter Rojas from
Gizmodo the whole of the story Nick
denge and I had quite a rivalry for a
while it was a fun rivalry too you know
Peter Rojas was actually the missing
piece with Brian Navi and I and once we
got Peter Rojas he taught us like hey
idiots like just come up with a name for
the blogs I don't want to be
gadget.weblocks Inc so then we made
the Apple dot weblogs Inc The Unofficial
Apple weblog TWA tuaw which people fell
in love with people were addicted to
trois because at that point we're doing
eight or nine blog post a day about
Apple and Steve Jobs were at it and
Johnny Ive and everybody and that ain't
gotcha became a juggernaut and it was
just a very like simple business and at
that time 30 million dollars was the
equivalent of like hundreds of millions
now yeah for sure it's a different era I
mean 30 million today would still be a
good chunk of change so let me flash
forward
and I want to ask you specifically
because it came up already about events
so you seem to love producing events and
you've produced a lot of events yeah
I've only produced one event in Reno oh
Tahoe it was in Napa oh it's not long
ago I have a friend who went she loved
it yeah it was a great event people
still talk about this event somebody
brought it up last year they do they do
it was called opening the kimono otk I
actually have a wine bottle from that
event over there because we made a we
had a wine making competition the
participants all engaged in and then we
took the winner and we bottled whatever
it was 200 bottles and gave them to
everybody
so it was incredibly elaborate
and I came out of that feeling like I
had just finished a tour of Duty it was
so hard why do you love doing events and
what is the smart way to do it what is
the J Cal recipe
in the Myers-Briggs I'm going to say
your intj or INTP nailed it intj yeah
but I could see you being a perceiver
but anyway I'm entj
and so you and I Vibe until such time as
I absolutely exhaust you and you need to
go to your room and take a deep breath
that's the relationship between intjs
and entj said uh this is for people who
don't know the Myers-Briggs which is uh
or as we call it astrology for men yeah
yeah that the Enneagram astrology for
men yeah that's basically it like we
don't believe in astrology but we
believe in this other thing where we
answer questions and it tells us things
we want to hear about ourselves but
anyway I scored 86 and 100 on
extroversion the two times I took it
yeah so I'm so extroverted that when I'm
with an introvert like yourself or like
say Evan Williams a friend of ours yeah
like I can burn people out I'm just I
want to talk for seven hours and like
when I've been on vacation with Tim
Ferriss it's like Tim Ferriss was like
well that was like an interesting 90
minutes with Jake how I need to go right
for four hours and or whatever you you
need to recharge your batteries take a
nap take a nap whatever and I if I talk
for seven hours I want to talk for five
more I just can't go to bed or I want to
start working and I so I think yeah once
you you have to understand your format I
think the reason why you're the number
one you know guy in podcasting is
because this format works really well
for you yeah you take a lot of time to
think about it you do your 90 minutes
and then you got a lot of time to
decompress and process for me I do my
show five days a week and all in six
days a week I like to talk every day
I'm like the morning radio guy right
yeah and you're like the weekly
60 Minutes guy yeah right and Viva La
deferrals the problem with events
is
some people who are introversed if they
do an event they need recovery time and
so for you to do an event
it should be you interview somebody on
stage
you then go backstage and write some
more notes and then somebody else
interviews somebody and then you come
back out and do a q a with the audience
and then the event's over and that's the
totality of the events yeah I did a
bunch of events because I realized if
you can manifest a community in a real
world space again back to like my
childhood need to be important or have
power which was based on having no power
and no money
and uh you know I feel like I've kind of
processed that now like I've kind of
processed it if I'm honest like maybe 15
20 years ago I kind of figured it out
but I I love the idea that if you host
the party those people get to meet new
people create some relationship or
moment that then changes their life
forever and so what you should be very
proud of with your open the kimono event
is that to this day people talk about it
as a peak experience in their life and
when you think about what our lives are
in some ways it's just like
Blade Runner when the Nexus 6 is on the
roof and he says like oh my God all my
all my memories are going to be gone
like tears in the rain well we have at
the end of this I believe I'm not a
religious guy I'm an atheist but I do
know that that singular moment in film
is the most powerful moment in any film
I've ever seen
and is kind of my spirit moment of any
piece of Cinema or perhaps even
literature that speech he gives
because that's what we think human
existence is about at its core it's a
series of memories you collect over time
you know you and I playing basketball
in the woods in Italy laughing our asses
off
and then you figuring it out right it's
just like this is a weird moment in time
that when I just start
describing it to you you and I just
start laughing we're yeah it's just a
great Tim and Jacob moment that nobody
else was there for it's just the two of
us like literally in a basketball court
hidden in the woods in on a farm in
Italy somewhere that we discovered it's
a really beautiful memory for me and I
think for you and yeah for me too we'll
get to the end of our lives and just
like that Nexus 6 that has us you know
this like four year lifespan and he's
crying for the Lost memories like that's
all you have yeah and then gone like
tears in the rain so make those memories
and that opened the kimono event I was
talking to them about it on Halloween it
was just two weeks ago very recently and
she was describing how that was like her
favorite event I was like you've been to
mine she's like yeah but that was the
one I like best and so even if that was
the only memory that happened there that
was the only tier in the rain you'll
always have that right and so for me
that's what it is people have these
incredible moments and I have them yeah
and I have now you know I'm 51. I'm just
looking at the next number of years we
have left and people of our age like
Dave Goldberg passed Tony Shea passed
you know a lot of our friends are gone
yeah it's wild Gone Too Soon and now I
just look at it I'm like how many more
memories can I put
into the memory bank before the tears in
the rain moment
so let's talk about friendship because
there are a few things
that come to mind when I think jaycal
and friendship I wanted to actually
sidestep and just mention something that
ties back to a few things you said that
I was going to bring up later but I'm
just gonna we'll bookmark this one but
this is a quote from October 2008 when a
lot of [ __ ] was going down people may or
may not remember if you weren't aware of
it a lot of things were imploding and
your quote at the time in the guardian
is everybody else is going to be
depressed and drinking and not working
so it's a great time to be an
entrepreneur so that ties into a lot of
what you already said but on Friends
I want to say two things related to that
the first is let me find this amazing
quote
all right so this is a quote from
Douglas rushkoff yes oh this is a good
one on the back of my book yeah yeah
Jason would never stab you in the back
he might stab you in the face though so
I really admire you as a friend and this
is not just for me this is related to
other people because you are one of the
most loyal friends I have come across in
my adult life and I've seen you defend
your friends in so many circumstances
where
a you don't have to out of pure
self-interest B there's a very good
chance it's never going to get back to
the other person
so I have a question for you and maybe
that'll be the first one about loyalty
the second question because I do want to
talk about all in is going to be how you
navigated starting a project with your
very close friends and all the conflict
that ensued because I have always
avoided working by and large with my
friends so loyalty where does that come
from and why and then then the
navigating starting a project with your
close friends well so much of what makes
us who we are is I think formed in
childhood so when you're a kid I think
you have this like computer hard drive
operating system and things start
getting written to it
and one of the things that my dad wrote
into it is like hey you and your
brothers your Three Musketeers you got
to be there for each other
loyalty above everything else you always
have to have each other's back and that
wasn't just like his operating principle
it was
you're gonna get in a fight on the way
to school we live in Brooklyn this is a
dog eat dog world I want to make sure
that you two you never leave your
brothers behind so that was like one of
his rules like if you saw two of us I
wanted to where's your brother
go get your brother doesn't matter if
the oldest The Middle on the middle or
the youngest you three have to be by
each other's side all the time never
leave one of your brothers behind never
let anybody say anything to your brother
always fight it's like one of the great
things my dad taught me and it stayed
with me and over time what I realized
was
one of my superpowers is being there for
my friends and being a loyal friend but
I guess the Doug rushkoff quote
you know I might be full contact at
times where if I disagree with somebody
or at times at times I might be like I
don't agree with you or like that's
stupid that's the ugliest layup attempt
I've ever seen Jesus what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you I showed you there's a little
square box there just aim for the Box
you've missed the entire backboard
there's a little box behind the rim
that's right anyway you could put the
ball in the Box your chances go up
dramatically you're like okay I got it
I'll put it in the Box
um but anyway I like to laugh I like to
be loyal and I think like
I have a large number of acquaintances
and then I have a small number of very
close friends
and uh you know that that seems to me to
be a good philosophy and then you know
somewhere along the lines you know
people become transactional with you
you've had this experience we've talked
about it before you know everybody wants
something from Tim Ferriss everybody
wants Jason to fix their problems or
they think they get a meeting with some
buddy who's more famous than the two of
us put together that that magically is
going to change their life because
they got to talk to the person and tell
them their ideas I'm like okay you're
delusional like this person does not
care about your ideas and they're busy
so like let Travis finish building Uber
he doesn't need to talk to you about
your startup like that's not gonna make
any difference and you know it's just
there's something really special about
being able to be supportive of your
friends and being there for them because
as you become more successful the world
people think the world gets bigger
oh you have more money oh your podcast
went up the rankings oh Tim Ferriss is
on his 12th bestseller the world gets
smaller yeah it gets a lot smaller it
gets a lot smaller and then you're
sitting home on a Saturday night when
you're famous or affluent or rich or
whatever combination of things you
succeeded in your life and it's a
Saturday night and you're like going out
to this event is going to be arduous and
painful
rather than delightful and you know what
I realized is you know for people who
have this in a more even a more acute
fashion than you or me
you know like you have to create
I think a safe space a place where you
know you can have like true friendship
and talk about things that matter your
kids you know your
your friendships your spouses your life
your hopes your dreams whatever or just
shoot the [ __ ] and watch a movie and
laugh and so
it's it's kind of like one of the great
things in life I think is friendships
yeah the friendships you get or the
effort you put into the friendships you
have right like and so people don't
invest in it and the people are so
transactional
it's actually kind of weird I was at a
Halloween party and a lot of people were
coming up to take pictures and I don't
mind it at all I'll take 100 pictures in
a row it's fantastic you listen to the
Pod I'm super happy I suppose for you
it's a little bit annoying the extrovert
introvert thing like I bet you can get
through about three of them before you
feel like you need to leave the party
yeah then I need a bathroom break I do
that at dinners I mean I'll admit
something embarrassing but you won't be
surprised maybe people listening well if
I go to a dinner with or an event with
more than eight or ten people I will
leave the dinner every 10 minutes to go
into the bathroom and just like close my
eyes and breathe
I will disappear and people are like
what's wrong with this prostate but it's
actually fine I'm just so overwhelmed by
the stimulation that I need to take
breaks it's really extreme well and now
imagine it's people who you know are a
fan of yours or think that they can use
you to achieve some goal right yeah and
literally all these influencers uh this
party really like their goal isn't to
just get a picture
and I was just had this like profound
sadness for them I'm like you know like
if I was meeting me and I was an
entrepreneur like
a photo is great but if you're a
first-time entrepreneur like maybe you
should ask me about startups and running
them or raising money or like there's a
million things we could discuss yeah
but the goal was to get a selfie who
cares you know like it just so anyway
it's important to be I think a really
good loyal friend I have been burned in
this regard where I've been more loyal
to certain people and they have not been
loyal to me
and it's very frustrating for some of
the people around me when they see that
happen to me and for me I said you know
that is that person's chance to learn
how to be a friend they just haven't
gotten there yet they don't understand
how much more special it would be if
they were reciprocating the friendship I
was showing them yeah you know and
it makes it just even more Rich for All
In
is a very interesting thing because you
and I are Solo acts yeah
and uh you have one duet you do it's my
favorite part of what you do is the
random show with Kevin
literally has had a profound impact on
my life oh wow a big part of why I lost
30 pounds this year you were telling me
how good I looked but I was in Italy a
couple of summers ago and you and Kevin
were talking about ozempic he had taken
us epic and compute and I went to my
doctor and I talked to them about
ozempic like a TV commercial and I
haven't talked about this previously
because I don't want to influence people
but I did a couple of
you know series of Oz epics along with
fasting that I learned about from you
and Kevin and using the zero fasting app
which I learned about from the show
and then I obviously hear you talk about
weightlifting and the impact that has
and so for the past year or so I just
did the Tim Ferriss Kevin Rose program I
did a couple Cycles it was empty I did
the weightlifting and I did the
intermittent fasting using the xero app
and uh yeah I dropped 30 pounds yeah you
look great man I said it before we
started recording I was like you look
really really good well done like to get
five or ten more pounds of weight oh you
know of like muscle and then be able to
run a marathon again so we get those two
goals that would be pretty happy you can
do it you can definitely do it I'm in
the window yeah so solo act suddenly
decides wait a minute I want to be in a
rock band
so tell the story what happened was uh
chamoth yeah and I had become friends
and you should explain if people have no
context what is all in what is the
premise of the podcast all in is a
podcast with four friends who are all
capital allocators in other words like
venture capitalist investors and
business Builders and I guess in all
cases four folks who are 50 years old
with 30 years of business experience
each so that's about over 120 years
building businesses or investing in them
uh getting together and talking about
business and then whatever the topics of
the day are but everybody's a little
unique and different
and it started as something we did in
covet because we would all play poker
together
and four of the poker players eventually
wound up doing this every week this
podcast
and this is in decade two of me
podcasting and so I kind of created a
format that I modeled after the
McLaughlin group
which was a Sunday Morning Show don't
know it so yeah this is Kai McLaughlin
you can look up some tapes of it anyway
this guy McLaughlin was super
cantankerous and he'd have like a
republican a Democrat an independent
whatever a young person a Bostonian
person a California hippie you know
whatever and he was always cantankerous
and moving the conversation along and he
would say wrong
it was like a very full contact kind of
dynamic interrupt each other
conversation but it just I was always
drew me in it's the best Sunday morning
political show of all time the
McLaughlin group and so tremath and I
had known each other from AOL he was
working at AOL when I saw my company
there the blogging company back in the
day
we had Matt he became a venture
capitalist and then he met Mark
Zuckerberg and he was one of the first
employees at Facebook grew Facebook from
10 million to 800 million users or
something crazy like that he was
responsible for the growth team super
intelligent considered fun thoughtful
guy Dynamic aggressive and interest
grade leader of people we became friends
we started playing cards together joking
laughing
and I said you know I really would like
to have you on my podcast he wanted to
be under the radar he didn't want people
to know who Jamaica was but he came on
the podcast in a lot of ways like Chris
Saka did our friend was one of the first
people I think I was one of the first
people to actually have him on a podcast
when I did my two-parter with him so
tomat became a bit of a brand after he
was on the podcast a couple times and
then he keynoted a couple of events and
we just had this Rapport and the report
came from just breaking chops and
laughing at the poker game every week
and then people saw that Rapport when we
were on stage and then he said to me one
time when he was coming out of CNBC
you know we should just do a podcast
together I was like yeah come on this
week and start up she said no no I want
to do a different type of thing just me
and you and you you know you just bring
up the news of the week I talk about it
then I ask you a question and then you
talk about it and we go back and forth
startups public markets facts public
private I was like that's a really good
idea sure let's do it um and we started
texting back more than what are you
going to call it and I said we should
give like a poker thing since it's like
poker we should call it all in
and so the two of us started doing it
but this is during covid so then we're
like well who knows about covid and
um sax had been doing a bunch of
research on and he bought ventilators
and he had masks explain who sax is so
David Sachs is an old friend of mine who
worked at PayPal with Peter Thiel went
to college with Peter Thiel he's a
republican independent really like
um chess club Debate Club brilliant
product manager created Yammer sold to
Microsoft for a billion dollars just
really smart individual but right right
leaning like seriously right leaning
like writing articles donating to people
on the right and we became close friends
our families would go on vacation
together just you know as close of
friends as you could be and
then we had him on as a guest to talk
about like hey what's going on with this
Wuhan flu thing and you know what's
going on with Trump and you know people
were very scared and confused that time
and then we had another friend who came
to Poker I didn't have a big
relationship with Freeburg at the time I
was doing from poker and David Friedberg
who runs uh something called the
production board he was an early Google
employee came on and he actually is like
he created climate.com and sold that to
Monsanto so he understands science like
at a very deep level
and so all of a sudden you know this
thing clicks and then Robin Hood and
that whole AMC thing happened and I was
an investor in Robin Hood and we started
talking about that and the show just
caught Heat and the dynamic between the
four of us people really started to like
and people were at home caught heat in a
good way I think caught heat in like wow
this is really Dynamic they're smart
they're opinionated
and they're successful and so when
people see that you've made a lot of
money is one thing I learned in my life
it's like the day before the weblogs Inc
you know Sal and then the day after when
I had no money and then became a
millionaire people treated me incredibly
different
like all of a sudden I got like 30 more
IQ points and I was two feet taller I
was like I'm the same guy but like
people just take you a lot more
seriously yeah and it just is a really
good thing to understand like literally
if you inherited a billion dollars
people would think you're a genius it's
a big failing of human nature that we
have this weird thing with the scorecard
that we think the scorecard of dollars
is like important it's not
long story short
all the stuff comes together and people
it seems to connect with people and it
starts racing up the charts
and the last couple of weeks I think
we're number 24 26 27 you know like just
top 30 podcasts in the world
Gwyneth Paltrow wrote about it in her
hoop newsletter a couple weeks ago that
she's obsessed with the podcast the
personalities and so you know this week
in startups had millions of listeners
every month and doing incredible five
days a week making millions of dollars
in advertising but it's a very Niche
thing it's just about startups so if
you're in the startup space like you
would want to take a selfie with me all
in has crossed over in a way like you
experienced with the Tim Ferriss podcast
and you know people who are pursuing
Excellence it's a much wider aperture of
people yeah and so this thing just
appeals to a lot of people and it's
literally people say it's like their
Sunday morning ritual or their Saturday
morning ritual it's replaced the Sunday
morning talk show and it turns out
Politico is writing some kind of a
profile of us right now because it's
become so influential in Washington
because we talk about the economy
technology and technology is having a
big impact on the economy and politics
whatever so anyway in some ways it's
become a hit uh it's very weird for me
because you know I've had a couple of
hits before but this one also is bigger
and I'm not in control of it I have
three partners and all three of my
partners on it
have never had a boss
so you've literally got four of the most
opinionated friends who've never had a
boss who have four different directions
they want to take it and it is a bit
chaotic and I'm the producer of it as
well and you know did all the work came
up with the format Etc
but objectively you know
chamoth has a series of fans freeberg
now has the stands sax has the whole
right wing so it's like a super team has
come together yeah yeah and it's very
hard to keep a super team together for
any period of time and this thing has
come off the rails famously like two or
three times
could you walk us through your favorite
of those three times and how it was
resolved
well
I wanted to do an event because you
mentioned before I like events and I was
like let's do this all in Summit I'll do
all the work
and uh you guys show up I have a
production team
um you know here's what it will be and
one of the four of us
was in a complete panic and complaining
and arguing incessantly because he
thought I was going to ruin their
reputation because what if it's not
great
then comes out of the gate people are
comparing it to the Ted conference
saying this is better than recode or
better than Ted and it's the new Ted and
whatever because we got the most
incredible speakers in the world showed
up for us just everybody I invited you
you didn't make it but I'll get you next
year
I don't know if I can afford your
speaking thing
but uh if it makes you feel any better I
know I remember this and I have not done
any speaking except for South by
Southwest I want to say in three or four
years yeah
so but no there'll be some opportunity
like it'll be a fun thing for us to do
and in my own defense I have been to
events of yours before I've gone to I
have spoken with you at events so I
couldn't make that one yes you did one
of those okay all right so wait where
does the conflict come in so the
conflict came in that I just told him
like Hey listen
I'm working over here you need to shut
the [ __ ] up and let me just do my work
and stop being in a panic attack all the
time and he's like my reputation I said
yeah what if it's bad what people paid 7
500 I'm like some people pay 7 500 I'll
take it for every event like it's not a
big deal
and then I
um gave half the tickets for scholarship
for people
anyway we had this back and forth and
then I told the person like you know
Freeburg I was like Freiburg if you
don't want to be on the show and you're
complaining so much I got Brad gerstner
over here I love how he was Anonymous up
until right now
okay the good news is Freeburg and I
after
like many friendships we
our time together but it was another one
of these like stabbed in the back
stabbing the face thing you know because
you got the quote from Doug I said
listen if you're not enjoying your time
on the all-in podcast and you don't want
to do the event why don't you do 25
episodes a year and I'll have Brad
gershner who come who sits in when one
of us is out as like the fifth Beatle
I'll have him do the other 25 we got
this big fight and the whole thing's
gonna explode and then there you know
these two are going to do their own
Pockets whatever and then we all just
sat down and we realized the audience
[ __ ] loves this we love it
let's not do any events let's not do any
spin outs yeah people wanted to do a TV
show with us you know top networks you
know all the stuff and you understand
how big the podcasting business Now is
better than anybody you know you got a
top 50 podcasts these podcasts have
become a very big business on top of
that my biggest media success to date
with my three Partners refuse to do ads
yeah this is one I was hoping you would
bring up so yeah I'm sitting here on
arguably 25 million dollars in
advertising which I would get a fourth
of and they're like sax is like well I'm
already rich and I got a plane and
tremont's like well I got a plan I'm
already rich I don't need a
I don't need advertising I'm like I'll
read the ads I'll sell the ads
they're like no it's like why would it's
so cheap to have an ad and I'm like no
it's not it's like every
everybody's got ads oh it's just an ad
people listen to the ad they drink some
athletic greens I thought grants is
healthy for you but we're done here like
who doesn't love it though Queens we're
good you know like yeah sorry to give
Athletics
Tim not jaycal use Tim not twist oh I
love AJ I was just texting with the CEO
Chris like 45 minutes ago you know I had
it this weekend I made a really good
Ginger
some other juices I think people drink
with water but I like a little juice and
uh what I do is now I use half the
amount of leaded greens but I do it
twice a day I kind of like to space out
my Athletics I like the ginger idea
slightly different but the ginger when
you when you blend that Ginger you have
that spicy yummy yummy but your partners
were not buying the the ginger cocktail
so literally like I could use another
seven million a year you know like this
is this is big cash six or seven million
that's a lot of [ __ ] money well after
taxes it would be a jet yeah so no I
have no jet
this episode is gonna get clipped like
crazy so I'm like guys
let me have a jet you're standing
between me and private Aviation
I'm being a little facetious right now
yeah yeah you know it's not exactly
facetious yeah yeah so anyway I just
said you know what I'm not going to try
to monetize this anymore
we're not going to do Live Events it
causes too much chaos let's just do it
every week and then I'm raising my next
venture fund launch four and I decided
to raise it publicly you can if you pick
a designation 506c you can say I'm
raising a fund so I said guys would it
be okay if on the podcast I mentioned
I'm raising a fund and people can email
me Jason boom
all of a sudden I get a thousand emails
people are like oh yeah I'm a rich
person I would love to be an investor in
your fund I do five webinars I really
hope the emails read exactly basically
it's like oh hi Jake how I'm a huge fan
of all in I you know my family office
did we do this I saved the whales and we
have big fans of the translation to 140
characters I'm rich can you make me
richer basically and so I kid you not I
do five webinars the last five weeks 44
million dollars in commitments whoa from
people I have never met my last fund was
44 million I have not done an in-person
meeting yet so I said you know what now
listen for people listening in the
Venture fund I have to deploy that money
triplet and then I get 25 of it I don't
get the 44 million it's not a donation
it's like what I do for a living but
holy cow
I was like I don't need to have the ads
on it yeah I can just play the long game
and raise a larger Venture fund and meet
a bunch more of these LPS or whatever
but every LP meeting I have
or most meetings I have now start with
hey
can I take a selfie and this is my
favorite thing about all in and so you
know it's like yeah I had to come to
peace with the fact all four of us that
we hit lightning in a bottle yeah
that's number one number two we have to
trust and love each other
and put on a good show and we have to be
rooting for each other and I said to
everybody like if we're going to do this
let's be rooting for each other and that
means when you're having this debate and
you disagree with me and like sax and I
have had blowout battles over like
Ukraine yeah and I'm like listen Putin
needs to be stopped and he's like the
you know Biden and these people are
tempting a nuclear war this is a very
important debate yep
and it gets very heated and you know
people think sax and I hate each other
sax and I love each other deeply even
though he can't say it I can say I love
sex and I know he loves me
and what I hope happened from that
podcast is people see that you know we
could have a a brawl still love each
other still respect each other and still
make forward progress and learn from
each other and you know Saks is right
about a lot of things with Ukraine we
should have maybe tried for peace
earlier a lot of the things he said
actually turned out to be right now it
seems like Biden is saying to zelinski
maybe you guys can start working on
negotiations now and maybe we won't give
you an unlimited supply of support like
we're giving you the weapons can you
please sit down and try to work this out
but it has created chaos and because the
podcast is so popular Tim it's
it's like a lot of things like people
maybe give it a little too much credit
you start to have a very big
responsibility now it's become a
responsibility and that exactly you
nailed it that's what I was thinking
like now people are calling me saying
hey you got to get Stacks in line and
then people are calling sacks saying oh
Jay Cal hates Trump he's got Trump
derangements I mean
everybody is projecting into this while
we're just having a conversation like
hey what gives you the right to have a
conversation about Ukraine what gives
you a right to have a conversation about
affirmative action in this Harvard case
right what gives you the right to talk
about
masks and
covid and what I tell people is when we
talk about things in our wheelhouse
Capital allocation company formation the
markets take notes
we're experts totally awesome we've been
at it for over a century combined great
place for you to learn if you wanted to
be a venture capitalist entrepreneur or
bet on the markets totally get it when
we talk about anything else
covet Ukraine politics where as informed
as you maybe a little more maybe a
little less you're listening to four
people have a conversation
go do your own research go find your own
truth and what we found
with covid specifically which was kind
of ironically where this whole thing
started and what caused it to start
Family Fare and pro public I don't know
if you saw this or like yeah we
intercepted some Communications it looks
like
it was probably a lab League yeah we
were sitting here 18 months ago and when
different people in the podcast were
saying well maybe it's a lab League they
were like well we have to take that
podcast down now yeah so we we can't
have that conversation that it's a lab
leak like yeah there's two labs in the
world that are studying the Wuhan virus
and one of them is where the leak
happened
I mean one of them is the one with covet
happened it happens to be in Wuhan like
there's 10 000 locations in the world
like pretty easy jump to make but
there's some weird thing going on right
now where people expect Tim Ferriss or
Joe Rogan or David sacks can't have a
conversation talk about a topic because
their shows are popular yeah yeah and we
have to work this out because
you are allowed to have a conversation
and people need to come to their own
truth and sometimes institutions do a
great job
sometimes they fail us but we should all
debate these issues if it's helpful I
can tell you my policy on this stuff
please tell me where I say my protocol
my protocol is if I'm going to talk
about something that I know is going to
light people up but that it is important
and I feel like I have maybe access to
an expert who can actually speak
credibly then I'll add in very strong
disclaimers and then I will not look at
Twitter for at least a week
I guess some self-care is very simple
it's like if you don't want the [ __ ]
punches don't go to where everyone's
giving [ __ ] punches
ouch my balls like you feel like
idiocracy the TV show it's like you're
gonna get your nuts kicked over and over
and over again just for having
conversation I think I thought Joe Rogan
did a really good job when they were
like hey you're having these people on
they have uncertain whatever and he's
like I'm a comedian and like yeah you're
a comedian with 10 million or 20 million
viewers yeah and he's like you know what
if I get it wrong tell me who to have on
I'll do it again but again I'm a
comedian
interviewing people and trying to learn
and I I actually think there's a little
bit of responsibility on the audience's
part here there is however I'm gonna
push back a little bit okay yeah let's
go I have declined or through vetting
disqualified probably 80 percent of the
people that might be on the show because
I do a lot of fact checking ahead of
time and I will do scientific fact
checking reference checking and if it
seems like someone is playing it too
fast and loose they do not come on the
show generally speaking so I do a lot of
heavy lifting on the front end which if
if someone's goal is to learn and
they're not a domain expert I think is
incumbent upon them if they have a large
audience and I'm not saying Joe doesn't
do that but I do think
well he said he doesn't do it he said I
totally being prepared yeah just to be
clear when this whole thing blew up he
said I want to let you know I do not
come in prepared sometimes I just have
like somebody hands me notes he said and
I'm thinking about changing that so I do
think if he's going to talk about like
medical stuff he should have a
researcher do some stuff and I mean
you're a very close friend of mine and
like yeah I know you do research I mean
but also I've got 20 pages of notes
which is why when you talk about
whatever topic you're talking about the
audience has an expectation that it's
going to be tight when people go into
Joe Rogan they should have the
expectation that he just walked in
unprepared or modestly prepared so
that's that's where like I think
audiences have to take some
responsibility it's probably between the
two things we're talking it's between
the two and you know I think that
and he might not want to do this but you
know if Joe wanted to
do something preemptively it's just like
at the very heading of the show there
could be sort of a disclaimer of the
kind of disclaimer you'd see on jackass
back in the day which would be like hey
these are trained professionals this is
for entertainment yes and do your own
homework
actually I have an idea for Joe Rogan
all right I think he should start a
second podcast it'll make
tens of millions of dollars called
after Joe okay and it should be a group
of experts vetting whatever was talked
about or goofing on it that's a great
idea it would just be like a breakdown
of what happened on the episode and then
he could say listen yeah
did you listen to after Joe or post Joe
post Joe wrote a web page like you do
great notes and there's people who do
show notes of both of our shows once in
a while that are pretty good he should
just pay somebody a thousand bucks to do
a show notes that they make so much
money pay three people two thousand
dollars each just spend five grand I'm
like this is a medical episode vetted
put a bunch of links in it that would
just make it so much better right yeah I
think so I have a question since I did
call you podcast master in the beginning
and I wanna I wanna put on a showcase
for a moment so you and I have offline
talked well I guess it's probably online
but offline meaning non-publicly talked
about how you prepare privately this
Jesus what am I am I a writer I used to
be words use your words Ferris privately
so you're a grant writer we've talked
about your moderating I think you are
one of the best moderators I've ever
seen and it's true and that that is
absolutely I would say that to anyone I
think I'm actually pretty sure I have
said it publicly you have actually thank
you for that yeah and I'd like to look
at the mechanics and the preparation
that goes into that because you've
talked to me about this and I remember
one of the examples again which is
hyperspecific which is
if you guys are on Zoom which most
people are not going to see like raising
your hand and using visual cues for
things so could you walk through
what the preparation process looks like
for a good episode we build a docket
every week for all in the docket I took
from Red Scare which is
like this Dirtbag Left podcast of these
two
women who live in the
Times Square in New York they're quite
charming and hilarious I
probably a little Cutting Edge for some
people but anyway the Red Scare pockets
is hilarious and dash always says oh
what's on the docket and have a docket
like you know these are the people who
are we're gonna pass judgment on like
before a judge so we have a docket I
make a docket every week with my
producer Nick
and basically we're in a group chat and
whatever links we share that week we put
in there and then we put bullet points
so the docket is a Google doc yeah
Google doc of topics and then this is
put into a private slack channel that
you guys use or something like that okay
we're on Signal yeah and so we yeah
that's where they all disappear within a
week
our lessons to learn
thank you for getting it so anyway
signal can't reach me on Signal so now
do you use desktop client for that to
make it easier to use or do you do it
all on mobile signal is desktop and
mobile now yeah it's pretty great and
it's not owned by the Russians do you
use mobile I use mobile and I use a
desktop yeah okay great anyway I have
the bullet points in there
and I will sometimes push people to come
up with topics so like hey when
Friedberg was kind of sitting back a lot
on the episodes I kind of dubbed him the
Sultan of Science and I kind of created
this character and I said you know
listen you're you're kind of like a
little bit of a Wallflower last episode
can you give me
whatever the most interesting science
story of the week is if I don't get one
by you know whatever a day before taping
I'm like hey and maybe I'll do a little
research myself hey what do you think of
this or what about that and when I get a
science topic out of him I throw to him
and you know he just lights up it's
great and then you know make a joke or
sax will go check his email and then it
sucks I throw him red meat so like the
red meat for sacks is like anything
political anything to do with the
Constitution anything to do with the
Supreme Court or legal cases and then if
I want to give uh an alley-oop to
chamoth so I think about us the
moderator I gotta get out of this guy I
gotta get him engaged Friedberg I gotta
give him some science so that he gets
excited right he's not excited to talk
about politics because he doesn't like
it
with sacks I got a tiger yeah and all
like a like a fierce tiger and if I
throw you know a couple of chickens out
there he's gonna Maul them and I know
what they are so I'm like okay here you
go Supreme Court decision loses his mind
oh here you go Biden said this and it's
inconsistent or boom hey here's
something with Trump he's gonna just go
crazy so now you got your lying going
crazy you got your science nerd coming
out of his shell and then with chemath
it's more like an alley-oop sweaters
sweaters Laura piano
conspicuous consumption no it really is
more about markets and startups and for
him I like to say to him
can you explain
this financial topic and why people are
talking about interest rates are bad for
tech companies why would the interest
rate have any impact on that now I know
the answer to that
but he can actually explain it better
than anybody on the squad yep so what
I'm doing there as the point guard is
like I have a clear path to the basket I
can just lay it in and do the layup but
I see him out of the corner of my eye
and I'm like you know what to make the
audience have a better experience is if
I pretend I'm gonna do the layup and
then from behind my back I throw it up
to him and he slam dunks it right and so
I've I've learned with each of them how
to feature them and make them really
their best selves
and then behind the scenes you know when
you see the point guard in basketball
like take somebody and they whisper in
their ear or something
I very quietly give them notes on their
performance and this is after each
episode after each show I did it had to
do it more earlier and then sometimes
I'll do it in the group chat if I think
it's something everybody can benefit
from but more often than not I'm doing
it quietly yep and so I you know I had
to say to Freeburg listen you know you
don't say a lot about politics
but I think your opinion actually
represents a large portion of the
audience
and although you hate it I think you
expressing a little bit
is going to be fine and if you're not
happy with how it comes out and I think
it's putting you at risk I will tell you
when we can cut it from the show and
once I gave him that sort of like I
think a little bit of a clear land
encouragement you will hear him talk a
little bit more about politics not to
the extent sex does and then I had to
tell sacks hey sax
when when I ask you something or I
challenge you
I am not disagreeing with you
I'm helping you clarify your position or
helping the audience understand your
position more that's very very smart way
to put it and you are attacking me
telling me I'm watching MSNBC and I get
my information from Rachel Maddow I
didn't ask you
to explain like one time I said just to
be clear
Putin invaded Ukraine not Biden correct
and he just went off or whatever and I
said you know the reason I'm asking you
that is because the audience thinks and
the feedback online is you're a Putin
apologist it would help your position if
you said to the audience
Putin and Putin alone is responsible for
invading Ukraine now how we manage Putin
and his unjust immoral invasion
is you know up to us right yeah and
that's what we can debate but I'm trying
to save him from being misunderstood
right and so you're like one part
moderator one-part coach one part comes
director
[Music]
oh in a way I'm not saying that is a bad
thing it's just no no no I think it's
super accurate yeah you're helping
everybody what I realized was I've done
you and I have done you know hundreds of
interviews with people great it's
awesome we're both interested in people
and learning from them and having great
conversations but this became came
something different for me you know like
being the orchestrator of the action oh
it's a different skill different skill
it was a totally different scale and you
know I had done these moderations before
at events but and I had sometimes done
round tables news roundtables but a lot
of times I was one of the featured
players not the point guard right may I
give one example of why they're totally
different in a one-on-one conversation
you can have a guest who monologues if
you have a group of people that can be a
huge problem how do you deal with that
specifically yeah it's two techniques
yeah two techniques very good so you and
I like technique so the two techniques I
have one of them is I say to people
beforehand
great job on the show today
at this moment in time you made four
really great points
it would have been better if you made
your first one or two
and then said I'm really interested in
what sex thinks of that or I'm curious
that's what you think and then you have
those two just write them on a piece of
paper there there'll be time for those
too we'll Circle back around but now it
doesn't look like you're taking all the
chips off the table because in a
conversation with four smart people
about a topic there might be five good
points to make
all four people might understand all
five points or four of the points and
then if somebody comes in and they're
just like
you know ding ding ding ding ding I just
took all the good points yeah there's
nothing left for anybody else to do and
so you want to share the ball a little
bit you took two good points you let
somebody else make a good point yeah you
could have made that point it was an
obvious one but you let somebody else
have it's a little bit generous as a
performer so it'd be like you know you
got some incredible guitar player they
come out and they just do a solo of six
minutes
Piano guy I could have done a solo for a
minute you could have done two we could
have given the drummer a minute and we
could have let the vocalist lead off the
song with an acapella you know moment
right yeah and so I've really tried to
be better at it and specifically try to
be better at it because people have been
critical of me for interrupting certain
people and so I had to actually adapt to
that because certain people if you
interrupt them it's a trigger for them
yeah or it can break their train of
thought I ran into this recently and I
was like I was well I wondered how like
how would Jason handle this I was
curious so I came up with another one I
said I'm going to give you the circle so
if people aren't watching right now I'm
just taking my index finger and I'm just
giving the wrap up sign but I'm also
nodding so I'm saying yeah
good stuff you know I'm giving you the
good stuff but like hey let's wrap that
point and then I'll just stop and they
finish their thought
and the other thing I do is I just use
okay
and I got that from Sam Harris I was
listening to those Sam's podcast
he gets people monologuing
these are some of the most brilliant
academics in the world on his show and
you'll see sometimes he wants to break
in
but I think in Academia it's even more
like difficult to do that just for
boating yeah for boat and that's the
word I was looking for my dyslexia was
killing me on that one
Britain for about it's for both right
you let people finish but he'll say okay
and it's like okay I got it okay you did
it and then the person's like oh oh Sam
has something to add and that's in a
one-on-one situation so you know you you
get good by studying you know I study a
lot of what you do and I you know you
have a way
when you're asking
a question of slowing down
and it's almost as if you're bringing us
into your brain for the formation of the
question
and I that was me imitating you yeah I
figured yeah and when you do it it's
like somebody at a dinner party who's
talking in a lower voice and everybody
leans in I know it's going to be a
[ __ ] important question when you do
that and I don't know if you've it's
unconscious or it's conscious yeah or
you are truly forming the question
but when listening to Tim Ferriss
when Tim slows down and Tim is thinking
I want to ask you one more question
I have it on this note here it's hold on
now it means it's a really important
question and it really does work as a
technique and you know everybody's
techniques doesn't have to work for
everybody like I talk fast yeah you talk
a little slower more methodically Sam
talks even you know more monotone he
speaks in finished prose unless it's
about Trump then I guess I'll tell
it is funny how we all study each other
right it's like oh yeah I love doing it
I mean I remember doing so much studying
in the beginning I'm still studying and
it's fun to notice because when you're
in the game and you're doing a lot of
interviewing
I don't do as much moderating so I can't
speak to that but you begin to notice
just like you noticed you begin to
notice the little things that were you
not also doing a lot of reps you
wouldn't pick up and it's about throwing
up soon yeah I wanted to ask you about
moderators so you mentioned the
McLaughlin group earlier are there any
people who stand out as good moderators
too
you know
horde of moderators yeah there aren't
that many I mean you might say what's
his name from Politically Incorrect Bill
Maher so Bill Maher
you know he can drop something funny
into a moderated bit so two people are
talking
and uh you know I do a little comedy on
the side
and we'll sometimes make jokes during
the podcast and
I have seen him do this particularly
well he's watching two people Spar and
he's kind of set that up and he's
leaning back
then he just lets like a little funny
thing out so as a device for a moderator
it's getting superheated and then you
drop something funny and you'll see me
do this on All In
it kind of just cracks the whole thing
open everybody's like okay that was
getting really serious but we're all
humans and we can laugh too about it
yeah so somebody's having some crazy
debate about like Roe v Wade and then he
makes some joke you know and you're just
like whoa that's a funny joke oh I can
laugh about Roe v Wade and abortion oh
my God I'm not allowed to laugh about
that like yeah that's a dicey place to
be but that comedic Interruption is it
works pretty well but there aren't many
people or shows that do it well yeah I
think you you could pull it off I think
with you know you have
you're a great Report with Kevin Rose
yeah and if you got one or two more you
could do your own little all-in
McLaughlin group thing it would be quite
successful I think yeah I guess it comes
down to the the chemistry like like you
said because with Kevin it's like we
just it's like having a good improv
comedy partner or something it's like
your Styles just work for for some
reason yes and then you can always
improve the craft and work on it but
there is just this Baseline of
compatible chemistry you know when you
look at your podcast player if I see
random show
that's just like I sniped that
immediately like when the random show
comes up in my feed because you know
what we're going back to Friendship we
talked we kind of spent a little time in
this conversation friendship is so
special right like yeah it's like one of
those very special things in the world's
unique and when people see friendship
like true friendship
it's so it's such a like intoxicating
thing to know that you and Kevin are
having a great time catching up and we
get to be there for it it's just to and
and I do think that is a big part of why
people have become addicted to all in
and we had like one or two weeks we took
off and man I have never had people so
depressed I'm so oh God what's going on
and then when the show was gonna break
up oh my God what's going on
that's just sucks man people wrote me
very long notes like you know I really
think you guys need to think about the
fans and what the impact is going to
have on us and I was like I feel like
we're in Pink Floyd and like Roger
Waters and Gilmore are like doing
separate tours and they're like it's the
same songs folks like
you could just listen to the old albums
I think there's another piece which is
right parallel to this and that is with
friendship
with friendship on display you get to
hear people also talking as humans
without overly self-censoring in a world
where that has become the norm do you
know what I mean yeah no when we had our
just now in our conversation when we
were bringing up ouch my balls from I
was like oh we're going there no are we
gonna get canceled for liking a funny
bit in a movie
yeah and and the fact of the matter is
as uh I don't think anyone will disagree
like if anyone listening to this podcast
had their group chats publicly shared
everything would be over right it's just
like they're chats with their five
closest friends all of us would be
unmasked yeah for the complete children
that we all are and yes goofballs
despite that given the times
I think the majority of folks feel like
they have to
have to put on a mask and stuff all of
that so far down because the risk seems
so high so when you have a show where
friends are having fun they're not
taking themselves or anything too
seriously even though they do take
things seriously in life right it allows
everyone to just exhale for a second
yeah chill out take off psychological
corset that they strain to put on in the
morning you know it's very weird like
being a Gen X or where like the Overton
window was
so much wider When We Were Young
and now the Overton window people are
like close it tighter or close it
tighter and I'm like who cares just the
window like you could
pick how wide or open you want it to be
but people are really
trying to like narrow the topics you can
discuss in a way that I find
kind of a bummer yeah you know because
all those conversations are still going
to occur they're going to occur in
private yeah I almost would rather they
be occurring publicly so we could make
more progress as a society yeah I agree
it feels like it's going to work against
us I hope it opens up that's why I was
talking about that Red Scare podcast or
another podcast I like is um the guy who
wrote a less than zero
and American Psycho Brett Easton Ellis
oh yeah and both of these are on patreon
and both of these are behind paywalls
which I think is interesting yeah both
of them are podcasts where people are
being
an overturn window that's twice as wide
open just for folks who are listening if
they don't know Overton window can you
just check the definition what's
allowable to discuss in society writ
large or you know I'm using a fancy word
what you're allowed to talk about in
society without feeling ashamed or that
you're being inappropriate or that
you're going to be persecuted or
canceled or persecuted for sure so there
was a time when you know just even
talking about somebody being a
homosexual was outside the Overton
window and if you brought it up
everybody would leave the dinner party
be a guest oh my God so you had to just
like treat a person who was a gay person
at a dinner party as like oh they yes
they've got a roommate you know and like
we're just gonna sweep that under the
rug like they're oh yeah they're here
with their roommate they split their
rent because it's cheaper yeah and then
you could be like yeah Ernie and bird
are gay
they're roommates
pretty obvious I like the little Judo
movie did with the Ernie and Bert there
like jelly and peanut butter I was like
well wait a second oh wow I'm just now
now it's okay yeah I like it I like it
yeah so you have this experience with
these friends you built this podcast
two questions you can pick either or
both the first is you mentioned
capturing lightning in a bottle and I'd
be curious how you would explain the
success of the show because there must
be you are so deliberate so deliberate
every example you've given
I think from at least your earlier
career shows how systematic and
methodical you are so I don't I know it
wasn't an accident it may have it may
have coalesced in a way that couldn't
have been predicted but I don't think it
was an accident so how would you how
would you explain the popularity like
what are the ingredients and then
secondly how do you now think about
success for yourself
and you you made that joke earlier about
being separated from the private chat
your friend's standing in the way of
this private chat jet blockers yeah yeah
how do you think how do you think about
success and or power because that played
such a role in your life up to this
point so the ingredients that made the
podcast successful or they make it
successful and then
the success power piece I think there is
something that comes from you know
repetition and getting reps in you and I
are both big fans of that and so I think
having done
you know whatever at the time maybe 13
or 1400 episodes of this week in
startups and all those event interviews
I came into all in
with a 10-person podcasting team I mean
that includes some sales people so
whatever
but having had done so many podcasts
that I came in
with so much knowledge and ability and
it was like oh my skill set but a
different playing field it would be like
somebody who plays ping pong all of a
sudden gets on a tennis court which
happened to me I used to play ping pong
as a kid
I bought a house and it's a tennis court
quite embarrassingly like it's like a
mind-blowing thing for a kid from
Brooklyn to have a tennis court on their
property you're like wait aren't there
like two in
for 10 000 people in Brooklyn and you
have to wait like to get on it and then
I have one where I can just sit there
and like Let It Go unused for a month
like
ping pong and Tennis is the same thing
there's a there's a net there's a ball
you put spin on it and I started taking
tennis lessons this year and it was like
whoo you know your brain kind of lights
up yeah
same thing but different skin scale so I
think that was like all that preparation
had led to this new thing that you
actually keyed off on and we talked
about last year for like an hour during
the winter of like hey what happened
there and so I think that's that was the
lightning in the bottle for me
personally was I maybe I'm a better
moderator than an interview maybe that
actually was sitting there the whole
time maybe I'm better better tennis
player than a ping pong player so that
for me I think has opened up a lot of
possibility of what I possibilities of
what I could do with the last
10 20 30 40 years whatever I got left on
this planet uh before the tears and the
rain moment happens and so it has opened
my aperture a bit and I am thinking
about things definitely wichita's with
your second question which is after I
made you know whatever amount of
millions of dollars
I had a profound realization like when I
go out to eat with a friend who's a
billionaire of me you and Travis were
sitting around or me you and Matt
mullenweg were sitting around and we
took out our net worth and it was like
oh my God like you and I are down here
these two guys are up here we all go and
have a stake
tastes the same we all go and go skiing
or we go to Japan
same experience and once I realized that
I was like for me it might be different
for other people
the scorecard of cash doesn't matter
yeah Beyond a certain point and for me
it was the freedom to do whatever I want
in my life and to take care of my three
daughters take care of my wife and be a
good provider take care of my extended
family if they needed some help on the
margins and once that happened I was
like I actually
I drive a model y
and I prefer that to the plaid and I
have a model X like I enjoy sometimes in
New York strip better than wagu I just
kind of like the flavor of it it's a
fifth of the price so once you start to
realize like okay this is these are just
constructs and money is just not the
right scorecard yeah the right score
card is did you wake up and couldn't get
couldn't wait to get out of bed like to
me that's the true score I cannot wait
to get on air and do this we can start
off with Molly and talk about tech can't
wait to meet with Founders I can't wait
to teach another course on how to start
a company can't wait to see my friends
for dinner can't wait to help my friends
if they're in need can't wait to come on
the Tim first box if I can't wait to do
the activity I know I'm doing something
right when you invited me on I went to
Jade I was like my wife's name is Jade
and I was like oh you know Tim invited
me on the pockets I can't wait to do it
like and I have never that that very
rarely happens but I was like you know I
listened to the Tim Ferriss podcast all
the time and I'm sure at some point I'll
be on it but the act of doing it with
you to me was like oh I'm excited you
know and
being excited and enthusiastic to me it
just means something has aligned yeah
you know when I'm writing you and I have
the same thing I don't know where it is
for you but somewhere around like a
third of the book things start heating
up for me and like you all of a sudden
like you know the first third of the
book is like oh and then all of a sudden
oh yeah I know what sections I have to
do I can see behind the next Corner the
book just flows and you're like boom 2
000 words are coming out at a clip you
know like those kind of moments when you
have that flow and you have that
enthusiasm for life
you have to construct the life around
those and then life is just pulling you
out of bed every day and just telling
you like
I gotta go to bed like every night I go
to bed and I'm just like I don't want to
close my eyes I want to just do another
hour it's hard for me to go to bed
sometimes because my enthusiasm is so
high for life and
you know it wasn't always that way a lot
of it was a struggle a lot of it was
trying to figure out who I was but I
really do want to enjoy
this last couple of Decades of if
there's an interesting project or moment
that's going to create that great memory
and going to make me enthusiastic I want
to do it yeah and if you know that means
helping out a friend on a special
project or you know going on a friend's
podcast or whatever doing a new podcast
it's just I feel very blessed that I got
here and I want to just squeeze every
single drop of juice out of that you
know box of oranges
really I mean think about it our friend
Dave Goldberg rest in peace you know
Tony Shea yeah the darkness there like
it can be over and it can be exactly
like our age range where we start saying
goodbye to people yep and so if you're
in your 20s or 30s like you're just on
adrenaline and then you get to 40s and
50s and you're like huh
what do I do with what's left especially
if some things have hit for you you know
like if you're Tim Ferriss and like you
gotta really start thinking like okay
well I'm one of the top podcasters in
the world one of the top authors in the
world is this actually making me happy
yeah right and that's the thing I'm
writing in my new book about is my new
book is about money and wealth and um
can't wait to read it I want to send you
some early stuff and get your thoughts
on it but I'm writing about this Paradox
that you and I are talking about right
now which is what happens when you catch
the car yeah what happens you know it's
it's part how do you catch the car
but then once I get you on the hook for
that like how do you get the money
now what happens when you have caught
the car and then now you have to look in
the mirror
I caught the car look at the adrenaline
rush is over
what am I actually happy did I want to
catch that car yeah did I want to beat
him first did I want to be Jake owl did
I want to be Travis did I want to be
Matt Molly wag yeah is this actually
making me happy what now and that's
where like Buddhism and a lot of like
soulfulness has hit me in my 50s or you
know right before my 40s basically when
my two friends died two of my poker
buddies died and it just it just
reprogrammed my brain in a major way you
know those two events and it's actually
been a gift
you know in a way because now I just
look at the world differently it's like
it's a big gift things in perspective
yeah I mean it does really yeah and you
know another pattern I've noticed just
with respect to catching the car is that
not everyone but a lot of a lot of
achievers I know who
have been driven enough
and worked hard enough and focused long
enough and sacrificed enough to make a
lot of money when they finally crossed
that threshold where they're where they
they can't really rationalize the need
to make more right which by the way I
mean I mean not to plug my own I haven't
done this I haven't mentioned the
four-hour work week in a long time but
if you actually read some of the basics
the fundamentals in that book it
outlines just how
much self-deception goes into believing
that you need 20 30 50 100 million
dollars it's mostly unjustifiable
totally and
when you get enough money that you've
won the game you always thought would
answer your prayers and remove all the
pain anxiety and depression and it
doesn't yeah that is a terrifying moment
and oh my god do people and I'll include
myself in this group of people yeah
begin to panic because you're like wait
a second if that didn't fix these things
yep what well what in the [ __ ] am I
supposed to do and it can be and you
know I don't want to make it a complete
swan song I mean look it's it's better
to all things being equal to have the
money than to not have the money however
the prevalence of depression in
quote unquote successful people that has
increased rather than decreased after
they catch the car is it's worth
studying I think it tells us a lot about
The Human Condition even if you never
end up catching the car yeah and this is
where doing the work internally and I
really respect the fact that you've used
you know some of the
the resources you've gathered to do what
the work you're doing at psychedelics
yeah thank you I've never publicly
talked about the Psychedelic work or
psychedelics period because I you know
as a person who sometimes people follow
what I do you know with a fan base like
yeah I talked about like actually taking
mozambic for the first time I think
there's things there's suffering in the
world that psychedelics are uniquely
qualified I suspect and uh you know
you'd want to talk to a doctor and a
therapist and do these things in a very
considered fashion but the fact that
you're
you know uh looking at psilocybin and
other people are looking at Ayahuasca or
other Academy or whatever I think the
research and the suffering that's
happening a lot of it is because people
have not done enough of the work to look
inside
yeah and find out where that trauma is
and maybe try and clear it and maybe try
to understand it
and that is I think the Breakthrough
that's going to happen in our lifetime
because of people like you and some
other friends of ours who have dedicated
significant resources towards the study
of these so I know if you saw Colorado I
think past I did yeah 122 yesterday yeah
it's big news very big news big news
Colorado is going to allow therapists to
do
all these different psychedelics in
really safe settings with really
qualified people for people who have
PTSD people have trauma people have
anxiety people have been to Wars people
whose lives have been Wars and uh it's
having a profound impact and if people
are out there and they're suffering
you know I really really encourage them
to go to therapy and to you know maybe
even research the stuff because again
you give these disclaimers all the time
on this podcast but there is help out
there yeah and you don't need to suffer
alone and sometimes people will mask
their suffering
and match their problems with
performance and this is the show about
performance yes absolutely and that's
why people listen to it and people are
drawn to it but sometimes we're drawn to
Performance because we don't want to
face the pain or suffering that is
driving that performance the fuel you
know like a lot of times those hot coals
that are burning
that's a lot of pain and suffering yeah
and uh it fuels an engine a mighty
engine yeah but you know then you get to
the destination like we're talking about
here and then hey
maybe this isn't serving me well anymore
right and you want it to serve you well
you know yeah agreed and I'll make just
a couple recommendations for folks one
this is this is an extremely
heavy podcast in terms of content but if
people are curious in
the capacity of researching psychedelic
therapies or psychedelic assisted
therapies but also looking at
alternatives to that I did do a podcast
that people can find at Tim dot blog
slash trauma which is a conversation
between myself and Debbie Millman who
suffered from a horrible childhood abuse
and we took very different paths but
found
Solace found support in very very
different ways and there are a lot of
resources associated with the blog post
in the show notes
that people can can look at the other if
people are interested in identifying at
least some of the credible institutions
and scientists doing research on say
complex PTSD and MDMA assisted
Psychotherapy which is
now believe through phase three and
psilocybin for treatment resistant
depression Etc if you go to
sciceofoundation.org that's that's the
foundation I started some time ago which
is
s-a-i-s-e-i which means rebirth in
Japanese scissay foundation.org there's
a projects page where you can see the
various universities and a lot of the
researchers I've been looking for this
to see where all the research is
actually occurring you actually made a
page I was telling somebody recently
like there should just be a place people
go to see where the progress has been
because people are not aware of how much
people I think it's next year that MDMA
will be available in therapy in some
psychiatric settings right if I'm
understanding the yeah I'd have to check
the latest and greatest it's certainly
last time I checked in it would be as as
potentially as soon as the end of say
2023 or early 2024 I'll have to check
there's so much in flux because there's
not only the Federal
landscape and potential
re-classification which you can do
through demonstrating medical need
because schedule one is supposed to be
and I'm painting with a very simplistic
brush here but schedule one compounds
are supposed to be drugs of
with a high potential for abuse that
have no known medical application and
rather than fighting the political fight
which you do have to fight at some point
you can demonstrate medical
application through good science and
clinical trials which has been the area
where I've predominantly focused but
then you have Colorado you have
Oregon as well and these parallel
systems or initiatives to create
parallel systems on a state
basis a Statewide basis that will be
very interesting experiments and they
could go a lot of different ways I mean
it could it could all go well there will
probably be as happens when therapies
scale
various issues and problems and Scandals
and so on I I expect that humans are
humans so they're going to find a way to
screw it up one way or the other but net
net the hope and I do think there's some
a lot of good that has come of say the
decrim nature decriminalizing nature
initiatives although I disagree with
with some of their stances
it's a very exciting time of flux at the
moment and as you put it there is help
out there and there are resources if you
think about what we saw happen with
cannabis in this country and yeah the
legalization of it like life went on but
these drugs are really going to help
people I think especially with the
complex PTSD especially with anxiety
absolutely
it's just great when combined with a
proper therapist yeah they're very
powerful as a friend of mine I don't
think he said it publicly so I'll
keep it Anonymous but very senior
scientist he said when you're working
with psychedelic compounds you are
working with nuclear power so you just
need to be very you need to have the
right therapeutic contacts around it but
they're very very very powerful
Jake owl yeah we're uh we're coming up
well I didn't I was like oh wow just a
quick 75 minutes 90 minutes yeah yeah
two hours two hours two hours two hours
plus is there anything that you would
put just as uh winding this to a close
anything that you would put on a
billboard metaphorically speaking like a
message a quote a word anything at all
that if you were to get a message out to
billions of people assuming they would
understand it
what might you put on the billboard
anything at all anything on the
billboard I wanted to wow there's part
of me that wants to tell people you know
to take chances and that they can do it
yeah like to give it a shot like to just
give it a shot right like it might just
work out like what if it works out give
it a shot what if it actually works out
that's my head speaking and then my
heart
it's just be kind
to each other
especially in the face of when people
are unkind
just notice that like people and this is
coming from me I go I'm a brawler I mean
I'm known for arguing with people every
problem but I I don't know what's in the
air I don't know if it's since Trump
been like this whole polarization in the
country but I would really like to see
people be kinder to each other
and just have like really open-hearted
discussions with each other and I you
know I think your podcast
to a lesser extent what I'm trying to do
an all-in I think there are road maps
here for people to have productive
discussions with each other that move
themselves evolve themselves and evolve
Humanity I think that's why podcasting
is such a special medium
and I think you know
you really can have productive
discussions with people you disagree
with you can have great relationships
you don't have to agree on everything
you could have great friendships so have
those productive discussions with a with
a big open heart and uh you know develop
those friendships it really is the best
part of life so for me I don't know it's
like the two best things I've done in my
life is have great friends and build
cool [ __ ] so I guess that's my billboard
I have great friends Bill cool [ __ ] yeah
I'll put a comma in there I don't know
if I'm about to have two sentences and
you know just building off something you
just said
you can have disagreements with good
friends and I would go so far as to say
if you're not having disagreements or if
you don't disagree on anything someone's
not telling the truth no because we're
all different and absolutely if you're
spending time with people who are
thinking for themselves you're almost
certainly going to have things you'll
disagree about and that's part of that
is part of
the relationship that is an asset to the
relationship but that also means you
have to learn how to
manage
conflict and resolve conflict and do
repair also and do repair you have
repair yeah wow that's that's a whole
nother podcast that's a whole other
podcast it's a whole other podcast
promise US Tim that you're not gonna
stop you know I get worried a little bit
of that I stopped on this podcast like
you can take a break yeah but don't ever
stop like I mean you're 45 if you do
that can you imagine if you do this for
another 20 years yeah like how great
this Archive of Tim Ferriss podcast is
going to be yeah yeah think about the
Legacy it's hard for me to see stopping
I've thought about taking a break after
a billion downloads which uh should
happen in the next few months actually
and I
as much as I fantasize about like
burning it all down and going to live in
a Hut in the mountains and growing out a
beard and like smoking a corn cob pipe
and reading books as much as I fantasize
about that
and doing cold plunges in a river and
running with my dog there's a lot to the
fantasy sure but I can't imagine
as you mentioned earlier we've had so
many private conversations and I think
both of us have come away thinking [ __ ]
why didn't we record that in fact she
made a fantastic conversation to share
would have been a great app yeah it's a
find of a podcaster I'm going to be
seeking out the incredible
Fascinating People to have conversations
with whether I'm doing the podcast or
not so I might as well record them
it's just amazing the impact it's had on
society I can't tell you how many people
like in just people don't know I know
you
and or that we're friends even and like
and so then I'm at a dinner party oh do
you hear this you know this podcast by
this guy with this odd thing and it like
all the time it's it's you're really in
pop culture in a way that's just
really impressive to me it's actually
you know what I guess I'm going through
it now with all in to a lesser
understand like it really is a weird
thing so think about being in people's
ears yeah makes it incredibly intimate
yeah it's very intimate I think airpods
specifically like these little things
that can you can fall asleep in your
ears you have them in your ears all the
time yeah and this the act of listening
to somebody's voice so often so
consistently yeah has created some new
phenomenon in the world and we call it
podcasting but it's really like this
like
lifelong friendship you have with a
personality you've never met it's really
trippy it is trippy it's super true
thanks for having me on yeah I can't
wait to see too man uh so people can
find you oh God oh God that's a whole
separate episode too
perfect perfect I'm just Jason on
Twitter yeah Jason on Twitter Jason on
Twitter and anything else you'd like to
mention before we wrap up closing
comments
complaints requests of the audience
I randomly tweet
tweeted months ago I just had this
Revelation like because I listened to
like three of your podcasts in one week
and I was kind of catching up and I just
threw a [ __ ] National Treasure it's
just good to know you oh thanks man I
really appreciate that congratulations
on like you know like it wasn't always
great yeah like that's true it was like
rough on the beginning and now it's just
[ __ ] brilliant so just
congratulations like from one person
who's been grinding it for a while like
it's just great to see you at the top of
your game oh thanks brother I told you
this in a private conversation it's just
like I listened to your podcast I'm like
wow he's on the top of his game it's
like watching like Michael Jordan or
something to play basketball it's
beautiful to watch like and you get the
best guess and they just now when you
have great guests on
they're enamored with you and it used to
be you're kind of like yeah I'm Tim
Ferriss is kind of what I'm doing they
come on and they just want to talk about
you and I'm like whoa this is tipped
over hasn't it yeah yeah famous person
yeah yeah is talking about your podcast
when you're trying to interview them I
was like whoa interesting to be Tim
Ferriss anyway we'll see you all next
time bye bye yeah
we tried to end it five times I know we
tried to end it five times because we
miss each other tearful goodbyes and uh
so I will say this Jason thank you
it's lovely to see you I am studying
what you're doing so it's it gives me
great joy to have you on and uh you've
inspired me to think about maybe trying
my hand at an experimental format with
with modern moderating a few folks do it
so I'll give it a go and this has been a
blast I've learned so much and it's uh
heard so much I never thought that I
would never would have expected to hear
so I'm
so happy we made it happen we made it
happen yeah and to everybody listening
as always we will have links to
everything we discussed in the show
notes at tim.blog podcast and until next
time be just a little bit Kinder than
you think necessary to other people and
to yourself
and uh squeeze the [ __ ] out of that box
of oranges every last drop folks because
we're all gonna end up on the roof as in
Blade Runner We're Not Gonna Last
Forever so make those moments count
thank you Jason I love you brother love
you too